[Music]
have you guys seen the new Netflix show
space for star and if CRO I watch baby
30 seconds same and I was like okay I
can this is so dumb really you watching
a little bit more like maybe like two
minutes and they're like I can't get
better
did you watch the office when the first
came out the office is for a true people
had similar sentiments when the office
first came out that it wasn't that good
first season I don't think is anywhere
near as good as the rest of the show
because Steve girls character was kind
of mean and like like too arrogant we're
and then he they soften them up I think
I'll give it another try it has
different because it's like if it's a
mockumentary and stuff like that or like
that setting but when you have a show
that's scripted and already off the bat
feels bad and Thane doesn't catch my
attention I was just like this it's also
very polished show - yeah and so that's
why I was if it was it was super
polished and it wasn't as good out of
expecting I just jumped out to be fair I
have not seen any other space force yeah
but I just heard that it's by the same
person that did the office Greg Daniels
great Daniel the jokes are way different
you know kind of like it almost feels
like you're watching like uh like the
rock or Zac Efron type movie where like
the jokes are kind of like Oh - on the
nose
I thought they may like like it was like
a scary movie epic movie TV show
really yeah okay so you're expecting
because the Greg Daniels at the office
and Steve Carell is starring in the
office that would be similar tone to
like the office and then you're getting
something if I was writing the article
about how bad space horses would you say
space force has failed to launch well
this is not a hit piece on space force
this is actually about how have you guys
heard about how Trump wanted to
it was reinvesting in space travel and
stuff and wanted to get us back out
there and he was thinking about calling
it space force or 2018 no comment about
it being space force because he wants to
make a real space force right yeah yeah
and so like you know so much air force
space force well now they may the US
government is having problems securing
trademark rights globally for the
spaceforce hello these guys beat up
sorry cuz good Daniel's all of it let's
go take it we take everything we want no
actually they're actually having
problems getting Air Force - oh they
because they just felt like well we have
it all right yeah Air Force Ones air for
and shoe they're good Nike sees it like
they seize property when they want to
make a post office that's not mark
Wright's work hey does little what my
country doing bad [ __ ]
so what the way treatments work is the
people will not get confused over what
space force with the government space
travel and space force to Netflix show
they won't go confused there the problem
comes when it comes to like merch or
people selling merch is big though air
force merch NASA merge yeah yeah so
people there's trouble like who people
wouldn't know who they're supporting if
they're supporting the epics you want
stupidest cuz from probably just said
that always like space for us right
and they weren't trying to plan it to
shoot like that but everyone like
whoever wrote the show was like that's a
funny name let's call it that yeah then
they came back and saw that they're like
that's what we want the name to be
mm-hmm little kids you know what would
be another name for like because it
makes sense
Air Force so Air Force was the baby of
the army it was like a development group
and then it became a big name armed
force though they're gonna call it sky
force that's sick as I 4 Star Force
Sky Force player on Star Force is sick
though Star Force is sick what's up my
for the show or for the actual like the
actual what's there why who's why for
what they're doing in space they want to
take over the world or galaxy that's
probably what is it always colonization
yeah well in and that Russia and China's
ahead of us yeah the kind of that we
have to be able to destroy enemies at a
moment's notice
yes don't you understand don't y'all
know what about that enemy within that
we haven't worked on the enforce the
enforce yeah that's it
what's the out force do the out force
holy [ __ ] yeah that's what you pin I
like that
I gotta go I gotta do it out for us here
can you believe that we can
scientifically launch a missile and then
launch another missile to hit that
missile to take out this guy [ __ ]
crazy dude and they call that [ __ ] Star
Wars which is sick everybody's just
copyrighting each other yeah that way
there's no original ideas that's for
sure I mean I was doing JK news before
you guys are doing JK news impossible
what would you call it call it um just
for last news news so you copy just for
less the festival that happens in
Montreal every year buddy to it no yes
wait you and he wasn't funny enough they
said yeah yeah yeah sorry I think you're
pretty funny whatever everyone else has
been saying about you I don't believe
them I think you're funny there you go
I don't think I'm that funny I would
agree I think yeah I think I'm just I
just people just like dab me around
you're personable yeah her friend was
telling us about how he it's on girls at
the bar yeah so he goes up to there he
goes hey I don't want I don't care what
anyone hears but say I think you feel
dude that that's happened to me is so
much I'm like I don't give a [ __ ] like
they say that yeah I've had people come
up to me and say that I'm like first of
all one of the people say in the office
yeah I don't care about you these fans
will not come down and then you build
them up and then they become so insecure
with themselves so they stay with you
it's right and they can't leave it
they're not allowed to
they say treat them like dirt and they
stick like mine for sure so bad we're
just joking guys but wait are these
never understood Megan cuz I'm like I
don't want to talk to you [ __ ] are
these fans come on time see we're just
random guys randoms huh yeah I just
randoms hmm this has only happened like
and I'm not gonna like this happened
like two or three times but not like a
lot of times unless that's a lot of
times I've got very approachable face
that's I think it might because I
separate myself when people are
socializing I'm like in the corner like
I just want a drink thank you what's up
you look like [ __ ] you are going date
[ __ ] you bro no
oh is this [ __ ] cuz one time my friend
wanted to go out she said we were both
single at the time and she wanted to go
out and like hit on guys and like get
drinks and stuff and I just don't even
like that culture but I was watching the
football game because it was on in the
bar and this guy came up to me and
started like be like but you can't even
name a wide receiver from the team or
whatever that's sexist yeah I can and
then I told him the wider also he was
interrupting the game that's the little
boy that you should do this to you and
he thought you were really yeah so bad
nagging I did that to you because I was
giddy yeah you did sort of smiling and
then that's what calls my boyfriend
essayist cuz you were in love with me
cuz I went home and I was like Stevie's
such a dick say any know anything about
football
I mean a sexist I was wrecking her about
the Packers because I knew way more
about the Packers and she did know it
wasn't about the Packers it was just
about like the Super Bowl in general
right yeah and then you fell in love oh
yeah I was pissed about him cuz he loved
him not bad not bad she did no I didn't
use me the others were in the Super Bowl
which this reason no it wasn't it was
the year after girls like [ __ ] and
they they do it to test if you can keep
up with them
I think girls like conference that's
what idiot guys say like she's nagging
us she really wants real i like busting
balls that's a love language but when it
goes past the point where you're like no
you're you're stupid you really don't
know anything about football and like
your dicks people but I never thought
that though yeah that was fun Steve I
get hit pretty hard sometimes you're
always like you're a dumb girl basically
jerk like he was trying to suppress how
much he loved you so he was trying to
convince himself you were dumb so he
would just like leave you alone he's
just so like I mean those aren't exact
quotes either I was a little more clever
but that's a rule how many home runs
they had for the Superbowl how many home
runs e yeah no they got they got four
goals
oh you think was a goal huh
they go - straight flush around it
probably think you probably think soccer
was sport do you got any more news on
the space people are like they're
surprised that Trump wasn't on it
because his whole brand like he's like a
master of a business right supposed to
own yeah like in licenses name out
basically that's how he made a lot of
his money was by licensing his name out
for golf clubs to use Trump steaks bro
sure Trump the vodka I love a guy who
doesn't drink alcohol trademarked isn't
it you just licenses PayPal yeah it's
great watching boy last night and like
one the beginning scene he's taking [ __ ]
from tower that's right I forgot about
that
Haidee sent off another drink and he has
his like a company drink doesn't mean
you can't make a lot of money off of
drink well how do you know it's be good
right because when they hold it up I'm
assuming they've tried in a like the
best vodka in the world yeah he has a
consultant that's a that's into alcohol
yeah yeah yeah you ask your homies
vegetto it's like it's like imagine like
you have a girlfriend she's like this
the best [ __ ] were you never [ __ ] her
and you tell your friends oh that's the
best let's go see well Michael Jordan
never wore shoes that's the quarter use
always walking barefoot yeah that was
the weird part of last dance
boilers I'm gonna watch it all it's
really good he wins a lot of
championship rings I open it oh come on
is there any dancing a lot lot there's
so much dancing what was his final dance
a crumpet what did you guys in earnest
not without spoiling it what did you
take away from him III watch myself two
episodes left and I'm already I'm so
like inspired to work harder at what I'm
doing yeah you gotta watch last dance
person there right there the people that
watch motivational to get motivated to
watch other motivation well bro I was
watching I was like [ __ ] I should get on
it
one reason why I haven't riding is
because I've been watching the last
dance with my wife
and talking money heist what yeah you've
been watching a lot of money house my
friend that's news to me
[ __ ] I was like huh you couldn't get
past [ __ ] huh I did emphasize it it's
my back yeah and you said in a weird
accent too and [ __ ] morning I came
from my soul what did you get of the
Jordan dark um I think I got like he
fell for it cuz he bought shoes for me
I got him what like I always wanted them
because I grew up during the Chicago
period I just couldn't afford them so
it's cool to build a buyer shoes but I
really liked it but the sixties no they
played into 90s I really like because
it's I feel like super driven people are
sometimes like misunderstood and it's
cool to kind of like feed off his energy
to see like for a lot of people like
getting into the NBA that's the
destination already you know
so you're like [ __ ] anyone that's a
professional athlete that's crazy but
then within professional athletes
there's still the 1% and that
[ __ ] thinks other NBA players
are [ __ ] lazy and I'm like that's
[ __ ] crazy so you're saying that
you're misunderstood no I'm just saying
that also you're not super driven no
okay that there's the 1% of the 1% of
the one-percenters and it's just crazy
to see like their mindset anyway when
you see space force in a movie or TV
show keep in mind news it real is the
government space for us or is it the
Netflix show I don't want to think that
much so I'm gonna watch it the show
shouldn't called houston we have a
problem that's it and the leads
character's name is Houston is it no
that'd be sick oh yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]